I pose the question to some of you which
was if the stove was fired up just a you
know a pitiful one beater per second
right so in other words like you know as
hot as I could okay so that's how far
away right now you guys almost
universally said to me no the stone
would not collide with the ball now he
just rehearse what was the reason why
why wouldn't it collide this ball would
come back down to the ground before the
ball had a chance to get anywhere closer
to the stone right now then you approach
it from another way of thinking about
this see here's what's interesting
right you tell me there's no there's no
solution right but I think there is when
I look at this equation what does it
tell you this tells you give it a
certain velocity that I threw the stone
Firestone right I'll tell you when the
two things collide now week was one in
there I get 180 what units of those
seconds three minutes seems like a
solution to me why isn't it a solution
okay
something plays this question to you
okay now I know this is not gonna go in
there but hopefully I need someone to
help me actually I need all of you to
help me get shouldn't get your phones at
your stop watches I'll stand over here
okay now you may need to know you may
need to stand up so that you can see
this because I would eat you to dirt
when this hits the ground okay maybe but
sound travels slower than the lights
now I'm gonna put this ball up on this
ceiling which are a 9-hour expert you
know it sort of shades of a measurement
have found that to happiness
okay mm I'm gonna put on the ceiling and
I'm going to drop it I'm going to drop
it okay and I want us to see how long it
takes
okay so you ready okay so I'll catch you
right after
I'm gonna catch it and you start and
then you stop when you think it hits the
ground
okay you ready three two one
okay how long wait five we got the
highest the highest time one second one
second we got the shortest time okay so
hold on stay with me
2.5 meters right I think the longest I
go is one second ten ten one second did
I want to get longer than one second so
so one second was our highest what was
the lowest who got the quickest time
half a second yeah point five okay fine
fine let's go let's go let's go right in
the middle right 0.75 did you know
there's an interesting theorem that says
if you have a on a big jar of jellybeans
you know there's get some competitions
if you get enough people to guess and
you take the arithmetic mean of their
guesses you'll get right on it if you
have enough people anyway so I should
have got more let's go
0.75 seconds to travel this far okay all
right now hold on a second
he's what's interesting if if I drop the
ball from higher right it would have
gotten faster as it went down you know
like say prisons if I dropped it from
108 meters right so therefore if I work
at this speed this just this big okay
two and a half meters over 0.75 seconds
what's that / 2.5 that must be about 0.3
0.8 seconds for 1 meter something like
that right yeah okay all right so 180
meters 180 meters how long would it take
what's that that'd be 54 seconds would
not 54 seconds except we know it's
actually gonna go faster than that isn't
it right because it's actually gonna
speed up we took that is like an average
speed but it's gonna drop in to go
faster faster faster faster 54 seconds
at the most is how long the ball takes
to go from here to here can you see why
this number is important I said when V
equals 1 when will they collide they'll
Klein after 3 minutes no that won't
because this ball got down to the bottom
before three minutes right can you see
this right this is actually putting some
restriction on how long this whole thing
happens right so this is all this is all
just us you know making em up
you don't need to guess you don't need
to estimate 54 seconds you tell me how
long is the ball in the air come on we
have equations for this right where is
it where is it where's equator on this
one okay that's that's where the ball is
at any time right so you solve it
let's solve it I want to know where when
the ball hits the floor right there you
go that's when the ball wait the floor
right and you go ahead you get T squared
equals 36 right and so T equals 6
because right you're 54 seconds after
all huh ok 6 seconds 6 seconds that's
all it takes for the ball to go from PR
to the ground okay hmm Oh bad ten times
faster we estimated what's listen to it
yesterday better okay anyway so
therefore now we have a restriction we
have a restriction on time right this
restriction on time implies a
restriction on V at least if you want
them to collide right maybe this one
okay that's when this thing is flying
right that's when the situation is
actually in play but I know what T is
it's this right at least four collision
is yeah now have a look I'm not all that
interested in this right so what I do in
this I just tell you well I can I can
multiply across because I know V is
positive right okay so I can multiply
across without lucky around way to call
a direction so therefore now you turn
this thing around and you divide there
you go hmm now just pause for a second
look how many lines of working there are
between where I left you and what we got
ads or watching a little bit sorry
goodness they go fine okay a whole a
whole eight lines are working if that
really okay but the thing is it's not
about the lines of working is it it's
about what's going on up here right
working up at this thing this thing is
important and that's how this comes into
play